hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
big fan of chemicals
and today i'm going to finally do a big
overview of some of the ordinary's
products
this brand has a lot of products and i
wanted to try as many as i could
and i only have one face so this has
taken quite a while
i could only get through a few
categories though and this isn't even
all the products i've tried
so i'm only going to cover a few of them
and if there's enough interest then
i'll talk about the other categories
next time so in this video i'm going to
be going through the direct acids
vitamins a b and c the hydrators and
oils
and the cleanses i've picked out the
best and worst products in my opinion
from these categories and i'll talk
about them today
remember that my skin is not your skin
you might really love
a product that i really don't like and
that's fine you shouldn't stop using it
just because i said i didn't like it
this goes for any brand or product but i
think this applies even more when it
comes to the ordinary because of how
they approach their product development
which i'll go into in a bit
if you like this sort of video click the
like and the subscribe and click the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos
[Music]
ever since they launched the ordinary
have really transformed the skin care
market
and i think they're one of the big
reasons that everyone is so
obsessed with the science behind skin
care now i think it's the magical
combination of being really affordable
as well as having the ingredient names
front and center on their products
so now we can suddenly afford to try all
of these fancy sounding technical
ingredients
and so we want to know what they do the
way that the ordinary have managed to
stay so budget friendly
is by really simplifying the
formulations of their products
this can work really well for some
ingredients but for other ingredients it
really reduces their stability and
effectiveness
and that's why i think the ordinary's
products can be so hit and miss
and the overall formulation the process
that the ordinary has cut out to cut
down on costs
can be really important so this is stuff
like making a formula
testing it on a range of skin types
tweaking it based on that feedback
and then testing it again and doing that
repeatedly to optimize
the formula can be really important for
making it work for a range of skin types
when dr javin lim and i talked to
dersium's chief scientific officer
i'll link that interview in the
description it doesn't sound like they
went through any sort of this
optimization process before they launch
their products
which is something that every brand is
meant to do
at the very least for safety reasons so
this is why everything is so cheap
but it does also explain the massive
range of experiences that you can see
people having with particular products
so you'll see a whole bunch of one star
reviews where a product gave them
masochistic acne chemical burns massive
irritation
and then five star reviews as well where
the product was completely life-changing
the packaging is also really low cost so
it's just a bunch of dropper bottles
and flip top lid tubes which means that
they can save a lot of money because
they don't have to buy fancier packaging
plus they can reuse the packaging for a
whole bunch of different products so
they get that
bulk by discount so some products will
go off a lot faster than they might in
different packaging
because some ingredients do really need
that extra protection from something
like an airless pump or a foil tube
so with a more expensive brand not
always but it is a general trend for
brands who really put
a lot of thought into their formulations
and their price reflects that
you can generally pick up any product
and there's a pretty good chance that
it'll work for your skin without any
unnecessary irritation
but with the ordinary you have to put in
a lot more effort
to work out what will and won't work for
you and a lot of people
who have more tolerant and forgiving
skin will really enjoy that journey and
experimentation
but if you just want to pick low-fast
products with minimal effort
and if you want to lower the risk of a
bad reaction then the ordinary probably
isn't for you
this approach also means that if an
ordinary product didn't work for you
then you shouldn't write off that
ingredient a better formula might still
work for your skin
so just be careful with that it is sort
of a cheap way to try out lots of
different active ingredients but
at the same time you aren't really
giving that ingredient a fair chance
one final thing i wanted to talk about
is that the low price
of the ordinary's products means that
it's really accessible
but it also means that it's really
tempting to just buy a whole bunch of
products and slap them all on your skin
it's like being a kid in a candy store
this is a really efficient shortcut to
burning the crap
out of your skin and it can take ages
months to recover
the fact that so many products are
single ingredient also tends to
encourage people to do too much to their
skin
when products are assessed for
irritation before they're released when
ingredients have percentages that are
recommended for use and products
this is assuming that you'll only be
using one or two products not that
you'll be piling five products on top of
each other
the ordinary's regimen guide is actually
pretty sensible they don't really
recommend more than two or three active
ingredients in a routine
but i see a lot of people do it anyway i
think the ordinary could make it clearer
that you shouldn't use that many
products at once because it's really
obvious that people
are ignoring their guidelines but i
guess people are going to do what
they're going to do
and it's hard to expect a company to
check what's in your cart
and then put up an alert saying are you
sure you want to buy all of this
so if you're getting into the ordinary
try not to get too excited
introduce one new product every two
weeks or so to your skin so you don't
overwhelm it and irritate it
and that way you can also really assess
if that specific product
is really necessary for you so let's go
on to the products
[Music]
simple formulas tend to work quite well
for acid exfoliants so
these are some of the ordinary's most
popular products
lactic acid is my favorite alpha hydroxy
acid exfoliant
as a reminder alpha hydroxy acids or
ahas
are chemical exfoliants that help dead
skin cells unstick
and so this tends to help with things
like clogged pores texture and
pigmentation
but they do also make your skin more
sensitive to burning with uv
so make sure you're already using a good
sunscreen in your routine before you
start using these
lactic acid is generally less irritating
than glycolic acid although it does
depend on the formulation
this one is really gentle and it can be
hard to find lactic acid products on the
market especially affordable ones
when this was launched i'm pretty sure
there weren't any affordable ones on the
market
i think the five percent is a really
good starter exfoliant or if your skin
is really sensitive and easily irritated
by acids
if you like what the five percent is
doing for your skin and you want to go
stronger then switch to the 10
and i really like that both of these are
in the range because there's an obvious
progression
the glycolic acid toning solution has
been one of my favorite ordinary
products
ever since i started using it it's just
a really simple glycolic acid exfoliant
a really simple no-frill sort of product
it also works well as an acid deodorant
if you want to go down that route and
the bottle is so big and is so
inexpensive that you can put it on all
the ingrowns in your body as well
the main issue that i have with it is
that it kind of does encourage overuse
with the name the toning solution
it sounds like a product that most
people can use every day without much
irritation
it's also only seven percent but on my
skin it feels stronger than seven
percent it's comparable to
other 10 or 15 acid exfoliants
so don't treat this like a toner treat
it as a chemical exfoliant
if your skin is easily irritated or if
you're already using irritating products
in your routine
then treat it really carefully but if
your skin likes chemical exfoliation
if you use it really sensibly if you
step it up really slowly
then it is a really great product if
you're wondering how to sensibly step
up your exfoliation i have a free guide
on setting up an exfoliation routine
i'll link that down below i also don't
think there's any need for a cotton pad
for exfoliants i apply them all with my
fingers
the cotton pad is also kind of rough and
so it adds some physical exfoliation to
your routine as well
and a lot of the time you just don't
really need that
so the famous 30 aha peel this is the
red one you've probably seen around
everywhere
i'm putting this in the worst category
because i know that it works for a lot
of people but
a lot of people also abuse it it's sort
of like say nice apricot scrub
there's nothing inherently wrong with
the product when it's used safely
but with all the hype around it a lot of
people are not using it safely
this is a really high concentration wash
off chemical exfoliant
it's the sort of thing that can give you
a chemical burn if you're not careful
and i really do think people need to be
experienced acid users before they start
using this
so it's for someone who's been using
chemical exfoliants for at least a few
years
maybe they've had some professional
peels as well so they know how it should
feel
and maybe they've over exfoliated a few
times so they know what can go wrong
i've seen people derma rolling over this
people using it every day
people leaving it on for way too long
the ordinary do have lots of warnings
about this so they do say it's for
experienced users only
they say that you shouldn't use it more
than twice a week although i still think
that is too much
even though a lot of people are using it
sensibly the easy availability
means that a lot of people also aren't
and so i think it's the sort of thing
where it would be better to have more
regulations around it
so for example if it was an
over-the-counter drug where you had to
at least talk to a pharmacist before you
could buy it
in australia it's actually illegal to
sell this product it's illegal to have
products that are over 20
glycolic acid at a low ph outside of
salon use
i used to think that this policy was
really unnecessary and overprotective
but now that i've seen how people use
this product and i talk to estheticians
and dermatologists
who have been telling me that people are
coming in with really bad chemical burns
and irritated skin
and just destroyed barriers from using
this product
i'm starting to see that yeah this
policy does make a lot of sense
retinoids are the gold standard
ingredients of skin care
they're really good for lots of things
like acne fine lines hyperpigmentation
there are a bunch of prescription ones
that are more powerful and usually more
irritating
and there's a bunch of ones that are
allowed in cosmetic products these are
generally a bit weaker
rational is the most common vitamin a
you'll find in cosmetic products
and it is really unstable it needs those
extra bells and whistles to make it from
the manufacturer to your house
and then once you've opened the bottle
it will start degrading and so it needs
to be slowed down there
plus it also needs to be delivered
deeper into your skin for it to actually
work
and with the ordinary you kind of have
the worst of everything here
it does have a brown bottle which
protects it from light
but the dropper is open to the air the
simple formula means that there isn't
much helping it stay stable once you've
opened it
and the lack of testing and optimization
means that there's not much
going on with the formulation to tweak
it to make it more stable or to make it
go deeper into your skin
there's actually a recent study that
looked at how much retinoids degraded in
products
they tested a bunch of different
products and it was really variable
and this is something that a lot of
larger companies really put a lot of
effort and focus and research into
neutrogena's formula is optimized and
stabilized so much that they can keep it
in a jar
and it has a two-year shelf life with
the ordinaries one with zero
optimization
unsurprisingly it is not so good in the
study which tried to replicate
real-world conditions there was only 30
left after six months the degradation
also follows first order kinetics which
means that the degradation happens
fastest at the start
pk also said in our interview that he
recommends keeping it in the fridge and
throwing it out after three months
and i just don't think that's worth it
if you want a retinal product
get a product from a brand that has
conductor stability testing
and is happy to stand by that basically
look at the packaging see if it mentions
stability
if it doesn't then ask the company if
they can guarantee the stability
if you're in a country like australia
where tretinoin is relatively easy to
get then i would recommend that because
drugs have guaranteed stability and
shelf life
on the flip side tretinoin is more
irritating so in that study i mentioned
they also looked at the ordinary's
granactive retinoid and they found that
it was really stable with only about 15
degrading after six months this isn't
really surprising because granactive
retinoids active ingredient which is
hydroxypinnaclone retinoid it was
designed specifically to be stable
studies have also found that it's meant
to be more effective with less
irritation
although the studies were all conducted
by the manufacturer so
there's possible bias there anecdotally
most people say that this just
isn't irritating at all there are a few
different versions that the ordinary
have they have the emulsion and they
have a bunch in squalane
i'd recommend the emulsion because
emulsions in general deliver these sorts
of ingredients better into your skin
but as far as i know the ordinary
haven't really done efficacy studies on
their formulas so it is a bit of a best
guess
i've talked about the powders before and
how i really don't like them
i think they're just lazy products and
they're really unnecessary and if you
look at the prices they are kind of a
rip-off
first off with vitamin c vitamin c is a
really good antioxidant that's good at
protecting your skin against free
radical damage from things like uv
it's also been recorded to fade pigment
and increased collagen
and that's why it's regulated in japan
as a quasi drug
the issue is that the effectiveness of
vitamin c really depends on formulation
and the best tester version which is
l-ascorbic acid
which is also probably the most common
one it is massively unstable in
water-based products
with ascorbic acid it's already a really
irritating ingredient and a lot of
people who are
trying properly formulated l-ascorbic
acid serums
are already getting really irritated so
this is like an extension of that
if you already like ascorbic acid and
your skin is made of steel then this
product might work for you
or if you want a product that you can
use on your body without worrying too
much about the price so you can just mix
this
into some body lotion your body skin is
generally less easily irritated
and you have a lot more leeway because
you're applying a lot more product
that could work but if you just buy a
pure ascorbic
acid from a supplement store it ends up
being a lot cheaper
it works out to be 80 cents for the
amount that's sold in this product which
is about six dollars
so i feel like there really isn't much
point to this product unless you really
like the jar or you're not sure you'll
keep on using it
or if you're just trying to use up your
free shipping the vitamin c suspensions
are safer products that have the same
benefits in terms of stability
it's a lot easier to dispense a safe
amount of a 30
product than it is of a hundred percent
product and they also don't have water
so they're very stable
but the instructions are really not that
great and i think that's why we're
seeing a lot of people
also getting chemical burns with this i
actually really like this type of
product but you have to
mix it with something else before you
apply it on your skin something
water-based so that the ascorbic acid
can dissolve and spread out properly
but the instructions do just say to
apply straight to your face and i think
that's where it really goes wrong and
why i'm hesitant to put it in the best
category
so i'm going to invent a third category
which i'm going to call the
category which is where i put products
that will work really well for some
people
honestly there isn't really a standout
vitamin c product
in the ordinary's range that i feel
comfortable recommending in general
so i like the suspensions but the way
you use them has to be
just ignoring the instructions ascorbic
acid derivatives can be a good option in
terms of stability
and less irritation but i really do
think you need to have studies to show
that they get delivered into skin
and the ordinary just doesn't have that
for their formulations
but if i did have to pick a best vitamin
c product from the ordinary i would pick
the scorable tetra isopalmitate
it's more stable than ascorbic acid and
i liked it when i used it but it didn't
have the same wow effect that i get from
a good vitamin c product so this would
be my pick if you specifically want
something from the ordinary
or if you can't handle ascorbic acid but
if you really want
a proper vitamin c product i would go
with a different brand
niacinamide or vitamin b3 is a really
popular ingredient because
it's really versatile it works for a
whole bunch of people it's not very
irritating and it does a bit of
everything so it can help with
acne pigmentation texture it actually
helps with irritation and restores your
barrier
and it's a really great addition to
sunscreen but it's an ingredient where i
think the formulation can make a really
big difference
my skin didn't really have massive
benefits from the 10 ordinary one
but it loved the paula's choice one so
with
something like this it's really throwing
the dice
and i really don't think you need to go
higher than 10 or 15
there aren't any studies showing
benefits with higher percentages and
there are a lot of dermatologists and
estheticians who are saying that people
are reacting to higher percentages and
niacinamide is in so many products these
days and it's not unstable like vitamin
c
so i just really don't see the need for
this product
i mean i can see why they have this
product because the first version did so
well it would be silly not to capitalize
on that
but in terms of people's skincare
routines i just don't see the need for
this
so they're nice and my 10 i'm putting in
the air category
it is their best-selling product so
clearly it works for a lot of people
but on some people it just caused them
to have really nasty cysts
and on some people like me it was just
really not that impressive
i actually liked it when i tried it but
then i tried the polar's choice and that
really showed me what nice and mai could
do
i think the breakouts that this caused
in some people made them think that nice
in my wasn't for them
but from what i can tell it probably
wasn't the niacinamide itself
it's something else in the formulation
so i do think this formulation is
probably giving niacinamide a bad name
which is a pity because niacinamide is
in so many products
if you're trying to avoid it you have to
avoid so much so
if you do react to this product or
you're just not impressed by it
don't necessarily give up on niacinamide
although i do understand if you're just
not willing to take that risk again
the order you have a lot of plant oils
and plant oils tend to be expensive and
they go off really quickly so it's
awesome that they have these
now no one needs to use oils oils are
emollients that means they sink into
your skin a little bit and smooth it out
if you use a lot of oils they can also
act as an occlusive which seals in water
but if you use a balanced moisturizer
that has all three types of moisturizer
so occlusives and emollients as well as
humectants which grab onto water and
keep your skin hydrated
you're going to get better results than
with something like an oil which is very
one
note but if your skin is dry then extra
oil can help and if you like the feel of
an oil that's great as well
also you don't necessarily need to avoid
oils if you have oily skin i
have oily skin and i really like oils in
winter when my skin goes a bit flaky
and also as a final layer to put on top
of everything else
i really do wish they had the production
dates of their oils on the packaging so
you had a better idea of when it was
going to go off but for the price it's
really hard to complain
my recommendations are the rosehip and
marula oils but different people like
different oils and some oils break some
people out and not others
so my skin works really well with
rosehip but other people say it really
clogs their pores
squalene is fantastic if you want an oil
well not really an oil but an oil-like
product
that doesn't go off easily it's the
hydrogenated version of squalene
which goes off really easily because it
has a double bond
double bonds are why plant oils tend to
go off easily as well they're really
reactive
so this has a much longer shelf life and
so if you're like me and you only use
tiny amounts of oil
then this is really good mineral oil
works well for this as well but i
personally feel that mineral oil doesn't
really sink into my skin as well
again it's not a complete moisturizer
it's mostly just an emollient so if you
feel like your skin is still drying
out or if it's not softening your skin
enough then go for a proper balanced
complete moisturizer
the downside of squalene is that it
doesn't have those extra antioxidants
that you find in plant oils which is why
a lot of us love plant oils
but that's the trade-off you get i was
really pleasantly surprised by the
squalene cleanser
because it's one of their few properly
formulated products and it's actually
formulated really well
it's basically a cleansing balm in a
tube so this is
pretty good at melting off sunscreen and
makeup not as good as some of the oilier
cleansing
balms i've used but it is still really
good it spreads nicely on your skin
and it washes off reasonably well if
you're not familiar with this sort of
product you massage it on your dry skin
then you wash it off i personally step
into the shower and wash it off with
warm water
i use this as my first cleanse and i
follow up with a foaming cleanser
i don't think i could use this on its
own effectively if i had a lot of makeup
on
but i think some people use it with a
washcloth and that tends to work better
i think it would be good if the ordinary
had a normal cleanser in their lineup as
well because i think this is just a bit
confusing for people
but i do really like it i got this when
i was in the uk
and i really don't like it it's not
approved in australia although they said
that they are working on getting
some of their newer sunscreens in
australia i'm hoping they'll be better
because this has a horrific white cast
and it's just really
thick and poor clogging i think
sunscreen is one of the products that
doesn't really work well with the
ordinary's business model
with sunscreens the formulation is so
important that you need to have those
rounds of optimization
and the ordinary just doesn't really do
that the natural moisturizing factors is
another
er product for me this is a really good
moisturizer if you have oily skin
and you have a lot of other moisturizing
ingredients in your routine so from
things like serums
it's really lightweight it doesn't add
much grease to your skin
but a lot of the serums from the
ordinary don't have those extra
moisturizing ingredients in them because
of the simple formulations
and this is just not a very complete
moisturizer i think that's because the
ordinary do sell other moisturizing
ingredients on their own so all the
plant oils as well as the hyaluronic
acid serum
and they expect you to use them all
together so that makes sense but i think
the range is really missing a proper
well-rounded moisturizer that will work
for most people as a really good
moisturizer
if you have dry skin this is probably
not going to work for you
and if you only use the ordinary
products for the rest of your routine
it probably won't work for you either
but for my oily skin and for my
completely disloyal routine where i use
tons of different brands this works
really well
but there are so many other really
effective moisturizers on the market
that i think you can just skip this
the azoleic acid suspension is another
air product for me
it's not an ingredient that i tend to
use a lot in my routine
there are some studies on it for things
like acne and rosacea and
hyperpigmentation but from talking to a
lot of veteran dermatologists
they call it an active ingredient in
search of a disease
basically some companies really wanted
to make azelaic acid happen
and so they just tested it against a
whole bunch of conditions the studies
use really high concentrations so
like 20 twice a day and so it's just not
a very powerful ingredient
and that also means there's a lot of
limits in your routine because it has to
work well with the rest of your stuff
because you have to keep using it all
the time
plus the formulations are just really
difficult because you have 10 to 20
of a powder in there but it is pretty
non-irritating and it's safe in
pregnancy and a lot of people have a lot
of success with it
this particular version is pretty
hit-and-miss it's got a pretty sticky
formulation that tends to ball up if you
use too much and if you don't use enough
then you don't really get those azolic
acid benefits
i prefer the paula's choice formula but
this one is more budget-friendly
there's also the proper drug versions of
azelaic acid which i think are always
the best
option if you can get them and if they
work well for you
there's just extra levels of guarantees
of effectiveness and quality when it
comes to a pharmaceutical product
so this does have some really great
reviews but i do think there are better
as a lake asset products out there
so those are my opinions on these
products from the ordinary do you agree
do you like the ones i like or do you
hate them or do you really like the ones
that i don't like
is there maybe a really underrated
product that i missed
let me know in the comments also let me
know if you want me to go through the
rest of the ordinary's products or if
you want to see a different brand like
maybe the inky list
if you like this video and you want to
see more like it click the like and the
subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog i've also started
trying to make tiktok videos so you can
check me out there as well
and tag me in anything that you want me
to bust in terms of myths it seems like
there is a lot of misinformation on
tiktok
thank you for watching and see you next
time to nerd out more